Marja Hoeltta Parsing JavaScript - better
lazy than eager.
MARJA: Hi, everybody.
I'm super excited to be here.
I work in the V8 team as a software engineer
and I will talk about parsing JavaScript.
This talk is going to be about V8, the engine
behind Google Chrome and how we parse JavaScript.
I figure if I'm going to give a parser talk,
I should tell you what parsing is to get everybody
on the same page and why you should care about
it.
I'm going to talk about how V8 parses JavaScript
and what you as a web developer can do to
help us parse better.
What is parsing?
So, for those who didn't see the previous
talk, the parser gets the JavaScript source
code and constructs data structures called
AST and scopes based on it.
I will tell you in a minute what those are.
Then the bytecode generator walks those structures
and generates bytecode.
It is then interpreted by the interpreter
and the optimising compiler also gets the
bytecode and machine code based on it and
the machine code is executed directly.
So let's look at some simple source code and
what the parser does with it.
The parser constructs an AST, an abstract
syntax tree, that describes the structure
of the source code.
For the function, there is a function literal
and there is a variable declaration and an
an assignment.
Every time we see a variable name, we create
a variable proxy for it.
We don't know what proxy it is, it represents
the variable.
The zero is the literal.
Then there is an if statement.
It has the condition which is empty here.
The "then" part contains for code.
There is another variable declaration and
an assignment and we create variable proxy
objects to recreate the name of the available
and then there is a return statement again
with a variable proxy.
This is the AST that the parser generates
based on the code.
In addition to the AST, the parser also generates
scopes where the variables are declared, so
now for the function, there is one declaration
scope, and for the if-statement body, there
is another scope.
The declaration scope Danes the variable A
and the if statement contains the variable
B. The variable proxies occur in the code
which belongs to that scope.
Then we do scope analysis.
This means we connect the variable proxies
to the declared variables, so, in this phase,
we figure out that all references to A actually
mean the variable declared in the function,
and all references to B mean a different variable.
And, to do this, it's not enough to just look
at the current scope where we are in, for
example, with the returns statement, there
is return A but A is not declared in that
scope.
Instead, what we need to do is that we walk
up the scope chain to find where the variable
is declared and now we find it in the parent
scope in the declaration scope.
Okay, so, this is quite a lot of detail on
one side, and, in reality, it is even more
interconnected.
I just couldn't draw all the arrows on the
slide.
This was exhausting to make and also probably
super exhausting to look at.
Look at this for a second!
Why should you care about parsing?
Here is a diagram where real world spend their
time in V8.
Parsing is the orange blob on the left and
turns out the web pages around 15 to 20 per
cent of their V8 time in parsing.
Parsing is on the critical path for web page
start-up.
According to Google's production web app study
a typical page spends around 370 milliseconds
passing it on mobile, so that's quite a lot
of time, if you think about it.
So this means that our parsing speed is roughly
one megabyte per second on mobile.
How does V8 parse JavaScript?
I'm going to talk about the two parsing modes,
eager and lazy, and why parsing is hard and
why benchmarking it is hard.
We don't actually have one parsers, we have
two.
They are called parser and pre-parser, for
historical reasons.
Parser is the full eager one.
It builds the AST and the scopes and finds
the syntax errors in the code.
The pre-parser is the fast, lazy one.
So, it basically just finds where the function
ends so that we can carry on.
It doesn't build an AST.
It build scopes but it doesn't put variable
references or variable declarations in the
scopes.
It is approximately twice as fast as parser,
and it only finds a restricted set of errors,
so it doesn't actually comply with the ECMAScript
spec but we are somehow getting away with
it!
Here's an example of how we use the two parsers
to parse your JavaScript code.
All top-level code is eager.
We use an actual parser to parse it.
We see an -
in there example, there is a - this is because
you want to call the function right after.
So we should eager-parse that.
In this case, the guess is correct, and there
actually is a call to this function so this
is eager parse.
Other top-level function are lazy parsed.
So we use the pre-parser for parsing that
function body.
Later on, at some point in time, you might
want to call this function so at that point
when you call the function, it is eager-parsed,
compiled and executed.
There are some other heuristics.
If there is an exclamation before the function,
it turns it eager.
If there is another comma, it turns it eager.
These are all eager.
Here are some trickier lazy versus eager cases.
The problem is we need to make the decision
which parser to use before we use the function
body or anything that follows it.
We need to see it when we see the function
took.
We assign a function to a variable.
This function is lazy.
There is no par 11 before it.
We use the - there is no paren before it.
The second example looks just like the first
one except we call this function an assigned
return value of that call to F2, but we cannot
know it when we need to make decision on whether
to parse or pre-parse, or whether to eager
parse or lazy-parse this function, so we end
up making the exact same decision in both
cases, so, in the second one, we also lazy-parse
this, and, when this line is execute the,
we need to eager-parse it right after and
compile it.
But it was kind of the wrong decision but
we just couldn't know based on the code that
we have seen so far.
So these lazy versus eager rules are not specified
in the spec.
Each engine is free to implement them as they
see fit, or they don't need to implement lazy
parsing at all if they don't like to.
V8 just tries to guess based on the syntax
which functions are probably called and then
eager-parse those functions and lazy-parse
the rest.
So why is this relevant for you?
So, it turns out we need lazy-parsing because
web pages ship a lot of code they don't execute
- at least not on start-up - so we want to
use as little work for doing, to do as little
work for processing that code that is not
needed.
It is also important that we pick the right
unto use.
If we eager-parse something that is not needed,
we're just wasting time, it is not necessary.
On the other hand, if we lazy-parse something
that's needed then we pay the cost at pre-parse
at the cost of parse.
The pre-parse is half the cost cost, so it's
like nun and a half times the parse cost we
need to pay.
The problem is knowing what code is executed
at start-up.
You can also force eager parsing by wrapping
function that is are critical functions for
start-up in parens.
There is a library called optimise- just that
does this so it should have use and that results
in speed -ups with most of the browsers -- optimize-just.
We should also minimise the cost for cases
where cases where we get the guess wrong.
This is an area where we are actively working
on in the attempt.
Lazy parse be inner function assist nor complicated
than lazy-parsing top-level code top to understand
why, we need to look at context allocation.
Here is some example code.
There is a function outer which is an so we
eager-parse.
That is a local variable called a.
Then it has an inner function that returns
this local variable.
And then this function outer returns a reference
to the inner function.
Now we call this function and assign the return
fall to f.
Now, f will be a reference to inner.
And then we call f and we print out the return
value.
So, this will print out to any, as you might
expect, but where is it coming from?
Normally, when you call a function, it is
local or variables are put on the stack, but
here, when we are calling f, we're not inside
a call to outer, so it definitely cannot be
on the stack.
So where is it?
The answer is it is in the function context.
So a function context is an object which the
inner function also refers to and keeps it
alive, so now we have the reference to the
inner function because f is a reference to
it, so that is how the function context is
then kept alive.
When f accesses when inner accesses the variable
a, it reads it from the function context.
If you want to lazy-parse inner in this case,
we need to know which variables they refer
to so that we can put those variables in the
function context and not put other variables
there.
We don't want to put all variables to the
function context because accessing them from
there, it just is way slower than accessing
them from the stack.
So normally, ... need to, so we need something
like lazy parsing with names, and the speed
for doing that is somewhere between parser
and pre-parser.
So this means that lazy-parsing inner functions
will always be heavier than top-level functions
just because of the semantics.
Modern JavaScript is heavily nested.
Everything is wrapped in functions, everything
is a module now.
This is a price you have to pay for, nesting
functions like that.
In some situations, V8 has to reparse code
that it has already lazy-parsed.
In this example, there is a lazy outer function,
no paren before the function so we lazy-parse
it and lazy-parse everything inside the function
too.
When we call this lazy outer function, we
need to do something for inner, and how it
currently works is that we need to pre-parse
or lazy-parse inner again even though we have
done it already once.
It gets even worse if you nest more.
So now, in the first run, when we go through
the code, we lazy-parse lazy outer and lazy-parse
everything in it, at some point, you call
lazy outer, so we eager-parse lazy outer and
then lazy lazy-parse parse inner 2.
We inner parse, and need to lazy-parse inner
2 for the third time.
Obviously, this is quite bad.
This is not how it should work.
This is something I'm working on.
Instead of lazy-parsing we should keep those
functions if we have already lazy-parsed them
once.
Why is parsing hard?
The JavaScript grammar is not ambiguous as
such, but it contains some constructs where
we don't know up front what we are parsing.
One is parameter list and comma expressions.
They just the same.
If you see (abc), you don't know what that
is.
Maybe it is a comma expression.
It is also possible that it is a valid comma
expression but not a valid error function
parameter list.
If you see A12, that's a valid comma expression,
but A12 is not a valid comma parameter list.
We don't know if it is an expression or not
until we see an arrow following the expression.
We cannot know.
For example, when we see the 1.
The other way round is also possible, the
A, B is okay.
It is arrow function with the rest, but a..B
is not okay and this is not something we can
know when we are parsing, we don't know whether
the user intends to use it as an arrow function
list.
How the parser solves this is it never rewinds.
Instead, when it is parsing an unknown construct,
it is parsing a very permissive grammar that
allows both kinds of constructs, and then
it records whether it has seen something that
makes it the invalid function list or an invalid
comma expression.
Then, when we see the closing paren we can
check if there is an arrow, and if there is
an arrow was it - so we just the check of
information that we recorded when we - we
don't jump back and reparse it or anything
like that.
So the parser has high-feature complexity
and new language features are added to it
all the tile.
Here is a typical parser bug that I found
some time ago.
It is eager parsing failings with that code,
but like what is this even?
So, there is a variable g, and we assign to
g an arrow function.
The arrow function has two parameters.
There is the destructuring x and then there
is g, and the parameter g has a default value.
That's again an arrow function with a body,
and the body is eval x.
So now, if I force eager parsing, if I disable
lazy-parsing, this fails.
We call the function g without providing a
value for g, so the default value kicks in
and this eval is confused and says, "I have
no idea what are you talking about?
What is this x even though it should resolve
to the parameter x."
The features involved in this bug are lazy
versus eager, a destructuring - destructuring
x, turns out this is not relevant - there
are default parameters, there are arrow functions,
and now an arrow function is used as a default
parameter to another rather row function and
then there is eval, and it's important that
the eval is in the body of an arrow function
which is a default parameter, so this is to
give you an idea of the complexity we are
dealing with in our everyday work.
Benchmarking parsing is also also non-trivial.
Here I have some mock benchmarks.
Benchmark one is not a bench - parsing benchmark.
It is lots of function with lots of code.
It is it looks like a lazy function, there
is no paren before it, and then the actual
benchmark starts the timer, calls this function,
and measures how long it took.
But now, if you implement lazy parsing the
way I described, we need to parse the function
when the timer is running, and this is really
bad for the benchmark, for the benchmark,
it would way better just to do as much work
upfront as we can, and like parse and compile
everything when the timer is not running yet.
Even though we need lazy-parsing for the web,
it really makes the benchmark score here worse.
It's a tiff trade-off.
There is another benchmark, benchmark 2, that
tries to be a benching bench marsh.
We start the timer, eval a lot of code and
then measure how long it took.
Okay, this is fair, like this definitely exercises
parsing when the timer is running, but this
is totally not how you load JavaScript.
When you load JavaScript from a file from
a resource, a wholly different code path kicks
in as in here.
And, for example, there are some improvements
we do for the standard code path for the normal
code path, for example, we download and parse
scripts in parallel, and these kind of improvements
don't benefit this kind of benchmark at all,
because eval is just not using the same code
path.
So, what can you do to help us parse better?
So, none of the stuff I talk about can be
sort of black and white, like, "Do this or
absolutely don't do that," I can only tell
you how things look from the parser point
of view and then you can sort of figure out
what's the good trade-off for you and your
use case.
So, a lot of this stuff you can find in a
blog post called "JavaScript start-up performance".
The first is sheetless JavaScript so we don't
need to parse so much.
[Applause].
You can also the code coverage, functionality
in dev tools to see what parts of your codes
are not needed or not needed on start-up so
maybe it is possible to lazy-load some of
that code.
You can measure the parse of your code and
the dependencies with the Chrome tracing and
runtime stats in it and you can see the concrete
number of milliseconds that it spends parsing
your code.
We have the code-caching, when you load the
same script, V8 detects that and butts it
in the cache.
The next time you load the script, we don't
need to parse it, compile it, we just read
the bytecode directly from the cache.
This affects bundling.
If you bundle a lot of your JavaScript libraries
into one file and then you want to update
one part of it, you lose the code cache for
the full bundle.
We won't be able to figure out that you have
updated just one part of the bundle, so this
is something to be aware of when bundling
and updating your code.
I already mentioned streaming.
That means we start parsing a script while
it's downloading, before it has finishing
downloading the full script, so it makes sense
to use this for big scripts, and to use them
optimally, you should load them as early as
possible and async and so the streamer kicks
in, and you can also make sure that the streamer
is streaming your with Chrome tracing.
In the event thread, there will be a background
and you can see the name of the script that
got streamed.
There is very little we can do for eval.
So, there won't be streaming for that.
There won't be code cache for that.
It makes sense to avoid it, avoid evaling
big chunks of code if you can.
In some situations it makes sense to use the
parens hack to force the compilation of the
critical path in your code.
This makes sense, for example, in if you need
to support older Chrome versions.
If you need performance across browsers or
if you need performance right now and can
wait for us to fix our - can't wait for us
to fix our code.
We are working on making these hacks less
and less relevant in the future.
There is time for bonus content.
This is code from the V8 parser.
It is a hand-written recurse descent parser,
so here we are inside this parsing statement.
So the return of that is statement.
And the first thing we expect to see is token
"if".
This is already checked above for calling
this function, and then we expect to see a
left paren.
If there is no left paren, then this is a
syntax error and we bail out of this function.
So then we recurse.
We call a function called ParseExpression
and then we expect the right paren after it.
We recurse again.
Now it is possible that the if part - thin
part - we check is in a token: ELSE?
If there is, we recurse again for parsing
the ELSE part.
If there is no ELSE, we do nothing, and in
the end, we construct the node for the statement.
It is handwritten, not generated by any rule
file or anything like that.
Here are some things you might want to remember
from the talk.
If you have further questions or comments
or want to talk about parsing in general,
just please get in in touch.
Thanks for listening.
[Applause].
[Music].
>> Hello, everyone, as you're going for the
break for the wonderful coffee, remember that
we have a community track.
There will be a lightning talk from a couple
of local meet-ups, including Up Front, and
a few user groups.
If you're curious how we organise events in
Berlin, go and check out the community lounge.
[Music].